[موسيقى]
بينما احتفل العالم بدخول عام جديد هذا
الاسبوع امضى سكان غزه ليله راس السنه تحت
وابل الجحيم فخلال اقل من 90 يوما سقط على
غزه وفق احد البيانات الرسميه 45 الف
صاروخ وقنبله ارتفع عدد الشهداء
والمفقودين الى نحو
و56 و500 مصاب وتسببت الحرب بتهجير مليون
و800 الف شخص نزحوا داخليا منهم 150 ال
باتوا دون ماوى وفق وكاله
اونور الاسبوع الث عش من العدوان شهد
تطورا مفصليا في حرب غزه اذ اغتالت
اسرائيل صالح العاروري نائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس في هجوم بطائره مسيره
على مبنى في الضاحيه الجنوبيه ببيروت ادى
ايضا الى استشهاد القياديين القساميين
سمير افندي وعزام الاقرع واربعه من قياديي
حماس وابنائهم العمليه وصفتها صحيفه
بوليتيكو بالتصعيد الخطير في الشرق الاوسط
رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس اسماعيل
هنيه عد استشهاد العاروري عمليه ارهابيه
مكتمله الاركان بحسب وصفه في حين امر رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
وزراءه بعدم التعقيب على الحادثه
اضرب خسائر الاحتلال هذا الاسبوع سجلت
ارتفاعا ملحوظا اذا اعترف الجيش
الاسرائيلي ب 510 جنود وضباط منذ السابع
من اكتوبر بينهم 29 قتيلا سقطوا بنيران
زملائهم او في حوادث عمليات بعد بدء
الاجتياح البري واكدت الفصائل الفلسطينيه
تدمير
825 اليه اسرائيليه منذ بدء العدوان ورغم
تهديد نتنياهو باستمرار الحرب اشهرا
اضافيه قالت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
الجيش قرر تسريح خمسه الويه قتاليه تعمل
في قطاع غزه منها لواء الاحتياط 500 و 51
واللواء 14 الى جانب ثلاثه الويه تدريب
وبحسب صحيفه تايمز اوف اسرائيل فان
الالويه الخمسه ستعود من اجل المساعده على
انعاش الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي على الصعيد
الدولي تصاعدت الخلافات العلنيه بين تل
ابيبا وواشنطن حول غزه بعد ان اعلنت
الولايات المتحده سحب حامله الطائرات
الامريكيه جيرالد فورد ودخل على الخط وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار بن غفير
الذي انتقد الخارجيه الامريكيه بعد
تنديدها بتصريحات له هدد فيها بتهجير سكان
غزه وشهد هذا الاسبوع تحركا دوليا قد يزيد
الخناق القانوني على اسرائيل اذ طلبت جنوب
افريقيا من محكمه العدل الدوليه اصدار امر
عاجل تعلن فيه ان اسرائيل تنتهك
التزاماتها بموجب اتفاقيه منع الاباده
الجماعيه في حملتها المستمره على
الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه من جانبها انتقدت
اسرائيل هذه الدعوه ووصفتها بانها استغلال
خسيس ومهين للمحكمه لكنها اعلنت قبولها
المثول قباله المحكمه للرد
عليها